all right gladiator i think you could  remake that one oh i think you could i  think you could make it good nick cannon  yeah tell you what drug lifestyle though  nick cannon from drums is this still  said in rome he goes up to the lion's  drums and he goes are you not in  entertain  nick can could full well be in rome as a  tatted black man from san diego drums  and gladiators  his drumline character that's his best  character  drumline is is a great film how about  this back to the future oh  no but if they did nick cannon  as as not martin  he's doc  he goes it only goes 88 beats per minute  too easy next don't do that for this one  godfather  i could see nick  he could be fredo yeah